after weeks of rumors and years of  delays publisher Ubisoft has finally  revealed concrete information about the  upcoming beta for its open-world shooter  the division Xbox one owners will get  their hands on the closed beta starting  January 28th it then arrives on ps4 and  PC the following day and runs until  January 31st on all platforms to  guarantee yourself a spot in the beta  you'll need to pre-order the game and if  you're worried at all about pay-to-win  microtransactions don't be the division  will have microtransactions but you  won't be able to pay it a level up  faster it's unclear what the micro  transactions will entail but Ubisoft  masses managing director recently  commented that all transactions will be  quote better the division launches march  eight on xbox one ps4 and PC for more  information on the game including  impressions previews videos and a full  interview with the creative director  magnus jensen head over to gamespot com